でお釈迦様がこの発見した 3番目の真理なんですけどね
昨日の話の続きですけど
で まあ 3番目の真理っていうのはこの幸福のことなんですね
で 生きることはドッカであるとね
まあそれが 1番目の真理で
2番目の真理は まあそれは渇愛の話で
それも昨日しましたし
えーと それでこの渇愛ということがこの生きたがることなんですね
とにかく生きていきたいって思うことが渇愛で
そうするととにかくドッカが続くということになるんですね
ですから ドッカが嫌であるならば
渇愛ということは心から取り除かないといけないんですね
ですから 心に渇愛ないということが
あの涅槃というんですね
だからそこは取り返しにくい
なぜかというと 我々は生きていきたいんだから生きているんですね
ものすごい生きるためのすごい欲望
希望 願望というのがあるんですよ
その欲望 希望 願望ある人が
それなくなったらどうなるんでしょうかと考えちゃうと
まあ大変なことになるんです
頭がおかしくなって終わっちゃうんです
死ぬことではないかと怖がったりもする
死ぬことではないかと怖がるということ自体が生きていきたいという欲なんですよ
ですから もうあの いくら頼んでも単純で考えませんだからね
あの 単純で喋る私が馬鹿だと思っているからでしょうかね
単純で考えればいいのです
渇愛がないと心に そうすると苦しみがないということなんですね
それで渇愛がない状態がお釈迦様がもうこれはまだ勝手に聞いたことがない真理だよと
誰にも聞いたことがないことだと
初めて自分が発見して語っているんだよと
それもまた考えてください
一応渇愛とか欲とか言っちゃうと
世の中にあるごく普通にある言葉なんですよ
で 世の中でもあんまり欲っていうのは良くないでしょうというのは聞こえてるでしょうね
別に仏教に出会わなくても
宗教に出会わなくても
日常生活の中でも我々はよく聞いてますよ
そんな欲なんかとかね
そんな怒りなんかとかね
とんでもないというふうにまあ聞いたことがあると思いますよ
誰でも聞いたことがあることは
何でお釈迦様がもう大発見だと
人類のは誰にでも発見できなかったんだよと
これが発見できなかったんだから
みんなもう苦しんでるんだぞと
おっしゃったんですかね
ただお釈迦様が自慢しただけですかね
他の宗教を知らなかったんだから
大体みんなこの みんなと言ったってもね
よく世間のこと知らない人々はよく自慢するでしょう
まあこれこんなこと世の中でどこにもないんだぞとかね
私は世界一だぞとかね
大体普通に人々が自慢することがありますね
それも馬鹿だからなんですよ
あの人は世界一頭がいいんだよと言って
世界一の人間と比べてみてもないしね
まあそうやってこのすごい自慢することっていうのは
よく耳に入るんですね
それでお釈迦様もあれほど大胆に自慢しているのは
お釈迦様も何も世間知らずですかね
だって普通世の中でね
大体は知ってますよ 渇愛はないっていう方が
欲がない方がいいとかね
それでまあだからこれも皆様方は自分の智慧で
知識で考えなくてはいけないポイントなんですね
渇愛がないということは何なのかと
それ知って 本当にそんなに大胆に悟り開けるということはあり得るかとかね
だからずっとお釈迦様がこの人間にこのクイズみたいな感じで
これ投げかけてるんですよ
だから簡単に語ってるんです
じゃあわかることであるならばわかってみろと
わかってほしいんですよ
ただ人人間馬鹿にしてるわけじゃないんです
わかってほしいんだから
すごい単純な言葉でお話ししているんですよ
単純な言葉で話して じゃあわかりますかと
そこはなんでわからないかっていうことは
自分の修行で頑張らなくちゃあかんですよ
ですから 私はすごいこの四聖諦の話っていうのはすごい素晴らしいと思いますよ
やっぱりこの一つ一つクイズって出してるんですよ
子供たちもいろいろなぞなぞというもう質問したりするでしょうし
この間子供に質問されちゃって負けちゃったんだけどね
まあ何ですかあの質問は
で 質問はその時宗さんがまあ生きていたならば
今も生きていたならば
日本の人口はどうなるんでしょうかと
ですから 子供のクイズだから考えてはあかんですよ
答えは日本の人口は一人増えるんだと
だからあの そんなもんですよ
ものすごい難しく考えるんですよ
全然答えが出てこない
だからお釈迦様の四聖諦の話も
ものすごくこのもうクイズかけてますよ
それに答え見つかったら
そちらにはものすごい偉大なる心の安らぎっていうことね
最終的な安らぎっていうことがあるんですよ
それは仏典書いた人々ね
経典ではなくて 経典仏典
私はいつでも区別するんです
経典というのはお釈迦様がおっしゃった経典で
仏典というのはそれから書かれたもの
だから大乗経典はすべて仏典に入っちゃうんですね
お釈迦様おっしゃったものではないんだから
だから経典は簡単ですよ
仏典は難しいこと でも結局はクイズに答えてないんですよ
私は子供の頃 経典読んでみるとね
何かない 何かないでしょうと
全部言ってることはわかりますけど
あら 何か何かないと です
そのすごくその疑問があったんですね
何かちょっと何かないと
これなんです これ何かないんですね
それを発見しなさいということなんです
だからそれもあの子供の質問みたいに
そのままあるんですよ
だからお釈迦様ちゃんと言ってますよと
完全に語っているんだよ
とも読むんですよ まあ子供に負けて
私はまあそれで 私は負けず嫌いだからね
私はさらに考えたんですよ
子供にもあれがちょっとおかしいですよと
もしその人が生きていたならばね
それが日本の人口や増えるわけじゃないんだと
人口を数えるときは もうとっくにその人を数えているんだと
と言ったものの でも子供も一生懸命いろいろそれに反対しようとしたんだけど
でも私もそれではあんまり納得いかないんですね
だから私はまあちょっとまあ数式で説明しようと思ったんだけどね
まあちょっとまあ 子供にとってはね
そこまでややこしい理屈を言う必要ないんだからね
まあですから この渇愛ないということに戻りますけどね
渇愛がない心が究極な幸福な状態
涅槃でやって解脱だよと言ってるんだから
もうあれやこれやとかね
考えても 答えが出てこない
渇愛でいくら考えたっても出てこないと思います
だから考えるところがおかしくなるんですね
生きることはドゥッカであると教えているんだから
それわかればいいんだよ
これ 4つの真理のまた 1つになるんですよ
生きることはドゥッカでわかってない人が
煩悩をなくそう 渇愛をなくそうと言ったっても
こんな無理な話ですよ
ですから 生きるということは何なのかと理解することは必ずしも必要なんです
ですから 自分で何なのかという実験をすることをまず先なんです
悟ることじゃないんです
じゃあ煩悩をなくしてやるぞと思ったこと自体煩悩だから矛盾なんです
これただかっこつけようと思うだけのことだからね
かっこつける必要ないんです
ただ 自分って何なのかと
それ見られないんですよ
例えば怠けが出たら あーとんでもない
もうこんなことだったらあかんぞ
なんであかんどる？あなた怠けだろうよということでしょうね
ただそれだけ 私に怠けがある
ただ単純にそれを認めないんですね
なんか消してやろう 消してやろうと
消してやろうと思うちょうどどんどん増える
どんどん増える だから大体この政治家みたいにね
一つとんでもないことをやって
もうみんなにいいかっこしてるでしょうね
で かすかにバレそうになっちゃったらとんでもない話でしょうと
私は命かけて国民のためにとかね
それで次から次へと自分が嘘をついて嘘をついて嘘をついて
もうどんどんバレて もうものすごい面目料になって
もう終わっちゃうんですね
最初からもう本当そうですよ
申し訳ありませんと言ったらね
私は国民に嘘をつきませんと
言っちゃうとみんなまあいいんじゃないか
それぐらいのことと言って許してくれる可能性もありますよ
だからまあどんどん増えちゃうんですね
だからヴィパッサナーでも正直に自分のことを見ない
隠そう隠そうと じゃあ隠してみてください
どんどん醜くなっちゃうんです
どんどん醜くなっちゃう
ですからもうありのまま自分の状況を見る
怒りが出たら これはもう怒りやと
怠け出たら まあこれが怠けやと
そうやってこの長い間
自分というそのものを全部ちゃんとラベルしてはっきりと区別する
分別する この小さな小さないろんなもの
それを最後にまとめて
自分という あの 何て言いますか
ブロックで自分を作ってみてください
何なのかと それで それで初めて
ああ なるほど こんなもんかと
それで生きることはドゥッカであるとわかるんですよ
あれ組み立てると この組み立てるこのブロックにもあるんですよ
つけるこの引っかかるとこ
そこが渇愛なんです 渇愛でつなげているんだと
怒りも憎しみも怠けも
もう欲もだらしないさ
だらしなささも いい加減なところも
全て生きていきたいというこれでつなげているんだと
生きていきたいんだから
どんなだらしないこともしてやってないんだと平気で言う
人のことをものすごく憎しんだり
嫉妬したりして もう他人に指をさす
あの人は本当にもう人のことよく憎しみもんだなとかね
とんでもないことだと
もうそうやってもうもう自分が善人でしゃべるんですよ
大体世の中の単純です
世の中っていうのは 自分がいい人だとみんなに言いふらしたければ
人の悪口って言えばいいんです
あの人は嘘つきや あの人は泥棒や
あの人は怠け者だと言っちゃうと
人間っていうのは屁理屈だから
なるほどこの人立派だと理屈つけちゃうんですよ
そうじゃないんです  もしかすると
その人曰く通り あの人は泥棒かもしれません
また あの人はインチキかもしれません
あの人は怠け者かもしれません
だから 聞く人はあなたはどのような人間ですかと聞いてもらわないと
あなたの話は分かりました
Aさんは怠け者で  B さんが泥棒で
C さんはインチキ野郎で
D さんはこれで もう E さんもこれで
それであなたは何者ですかと
だからそこは誰も聞かないでしょうに
そういうことだから もうみんなもうお互いに騙し合って生きているんですね
お互いに だからお釈迦様がはっきり言ったんでおっしゃったんです
お釈迦様はそうじゃない
私が悟ったんだよと私が言ってるんだよと
では あなた方知らんでしょう
そんなことは だから私はブッダですよ
先生ですよとか そんな尊敬は置いておいて
調べてください とことん調べてください
そこがすごいところなんです
それが世の中でお釈迦様以外はほとんど言ってないんです
どうぞ調べてください
他の宗教の経典を読んでみてください
この経典に批判したら地獄に落ちますよと
頭が 7つに割れるぞと
あんな話を聞いて ああ
やっぱりゴミだと私は
だからもうもうだからゴミやと
嘘を言ってるんだから
そういうふうに脅しかけるんですよ
本当のことを言ってるんだったら
じゃあ私が言ったことは本当かないかと
あなた方は調べてくださいと言うんです
やっぱりこのお釈迦様がですからきちんと調べなさいと
とは言うんですね だから調べてるとブッダが悟ってるっていうことはわかるんです
あの それは本当にある人が調べたんですよ
あるこの 80歳ぐらいのものすごいインテリのバラモンがいて
ものすごいたくさん弟子たちがいたんです
ものすごい先生で 彼がブッダの話を聞いたんです
名前はセーラという名前なんですけどね
何か悟った悟った人は
いるんだよと話聞いて
でも彼がそんな単純であ
そうですか じゃあみんなで行って信仰しましょうっていうのはね
現代人じゃないんだからね
もうあまり行かなかったんです
その代わりに自分のところに
もう天才みたいな能力ある若者がいたんですよ
その若者の学問能力もほとんど先生と同じ
だから先生にとってはもうすごい勉強できた子だからね
これまたすごい可愛いでしょうし
言って その人にこそこそと頼むんですよ
君 こういう話聞いたんだけどね
まあ悟ってる人がいるんだと
この我々はもうこの心のことはあまり知りませんだけど
占いの世界だからね それぐらいの徳のある人だったら
この人相でわかるんだよと
ですから もうその子に全部教えたんです
彼も別に関係ないんだから
世の中でありえないということだから
別に教えてなかったみたいです
それで全部このこういう人相
こういうこういうこういうことだよ
君いて調べてみなさいと
言ったら その若者がお釈迦様のところに行って
挨拶はしないし 別に自分何者かとも言わないで
ただみんなの中に入ってじーっと話を聞いたり
で  3ヶ月間調べたんです
1日だけではなくて ずっと一緒に
お釈迦様歩く時でも一緒に行く
後ろから 托鉢に行く時も一緒に行って調べると
ご飯食べる時でも お話する時でも
全部調べて まあ 2つぐらいの人相は見えなかったので
衣で隠して隠れていたんだからね
で それでももう信頼しない
もう他のは全部丸で また 2つ残っている
それを釈迦様に言わなきゃわからないんだから
お釈迦様に行ったんですね
私は 3ヶ月間あんたを調べたんですけど
またポイント2つ残ってましたよと
言ったら お釈迦様がそうと言って
その人相 2つを見せたんですね
衣で お釈迦様はすごい
もうすごい もう素朴でね
すごいもう地方なんですよ
何も何の見えもなくてね
その 2つあんた気になるの？と言って
じゃあいいよと 言って
これとこれでしょうってことでね
それ見せて で それで彼がもう全部点数はもう OK だからね
で 先生に報告するんですよ
先生に報告したのはこの人相のことじゃないんですね
人格なんですよ お釈迦様の
先生言って人相って置いといて
あの人は本当すごい人ですよ
歩く時はこういう歩き方で
食べるときはこういう食べ方で
喋るときはこういう喋り方ですよ
こういう内容で こういう風に喋る人ですよと
ですから 先生が言って
そのブッダに会って話すのは何のこともない
もう先生が言って話すべきですよと
言ったら 先生もすごいできた人で
あんた若者の話誰が聞くんですかとかね
そんなことはなく 君が言うならば
じゃあみんなで行きましょうと
言って 自分の弟子たちみんな集めてお釈迦様に会いに行ったんですよ
その人  80歳ぐらいのすごい歳でしたけどね
このセーラというバラモンが
まあそういうことだから
やっぱりブッダはすごいオープンで
調べなさいという立場で言ってるんですね
まあそういう話で まあやっぱりこの心はね
まあ解脱を体験するんだということをね
まあ渇愛がなくなったら
で 簡単単純ですけど  我々はその苦しさをね
我々はもう解読しないと
だからそのためにやることは自分で何なのかと
本当に生きることはどこでしょうかとと観察することなんですね
それに人の話を持ってきたらとんでもないことなんです
誰かがやっぱりそうじゃないと言ってるんだよと
誰かさんが何言ったってどうでもいいんですよ
私も生きてるんだから
生きることは楽しい すごい幸福のもう満ち溢れているものだったら
自分で知ってるで なんで人の話聞くんですかね
自分も生きてるんだからね
そういうことで意味がない
それも無知な人のやり方なんですね
何々さんが人生は素晴らしいものと言ってるんだから
また何々さんが生きること自体すごい幸福だと言ってるんだからとか
何々さんがもういろんなどうでもいいことで
何々さんが言うことがね
自分も生きてるんだから
だから自分がどう思いますかということで
それは人の話 まあ置いといて
直接ありのままに 正直に
科学者のつもりで 一つ一つ見極めればいいんですね
それで発見できます 観察する一項一項の項目は全部もう苦しみであって空しいものだ
それでもなんで生きてきたんでしょうかと思えば
このつなげることが見つかるんです
あ これでつなげているんだと
ですから 渇愛が捨てたところで
この苦しみというものが消えるんだよということをお釈迦様はおっしゃっているんですけど
悟ったら人が死ぬんだぞとは一度も言ってないんですね
でも 生きるためには欲が必要だよといえば
それは正しいんですよ
みんな欲があるんだから生きてるということはね
だったら欲が捨てちゃうと死ぬというのをお釈迦様おっしゃってないんです
だったら欲のままで死んだっていうのは楽でしょうに
また欲まで捨てて死ぬと
もう苦労多いんだから
そんな  そんな苦労しなくていいんだったら
じゃあ早く死ねと そういう屁理屈ではないんですね
だから まあ欲がなくなったら大変だなと思うことが
まあもうそういう それはもう大変誤解で
まあ欲の思考なんですね
それ自体が まあそういうことで
僅かにでも欲が薄くなるとかね
もうしがみついて生きていきたいという気持ちがもうなんか薄れていくとかね
その時は気持ちはどうですかと
生きづらくなるんですかと
本当に自分がはっきりと死ぬんだぞと
あと二 三年だよと 聞いてもらったら楽になるんですよ
ものすごく楽になるんです
あなたにはもう治療がないと
すごく楽になるんです
だから生きていきたいと思うと苦しみがあるんですよ
例えば自分の病気には
まあどこかに治療があるんかもしれませんと
思っちゃうと 世界中治療探して回るでしょうに
それが楽しいんですかね
あるところに行って 今なんとかこういう病気だから治療してくださいと
医者もインチキ屋だからだいぶ分かりましたと
それで自慢する 私のところにもうかなり遠くから患者さんが来ましたよと
行って治療する でも治らないと
また他のところに行くと
また治療してまた治らないということになるでしょうね
途中で死ぬんだけど それでも悔しく死ぬ
もしかするとあるんだけど
私がもう残念ながら見つからなかったんだぞと
だからものすごい苦しみで死ぬだけで
まあ治療はないんだよと
まあいいやと思っちゃえば
それだけでいかに楽になるかと
それで ああそう死ぬんですかと
知っただけで人が死にますかね
死ぬ時は死ぬんであって
だから仏教はもう死っていうことを瞑想しなさいと
はっきり死ぬんだと覚えておけば
それだけでもすごく楽になるんですよ
死の瞑想しちゃうと この 3種類の渇愛で
このバワタンハット  2番目
が薄くなるんですね  2番目薄くなると 1番目もかなり薄くなるんですよ
例えば誰が楽ですかね
世界一美味しいごちそうしか食わんぞと思う人と
まあ適当に何かあればもう十分だよと思う人の間で誰が楽ですかね
もう分かりきってることでしょうに
誰が気楽に生きてられるんですかと
銀のフォークでなきゃ食べませんという人が山登ったらどうするんですかね
そうなんでもしたら死んじゃうでしょうに
アホだが そこらにあるもの
ある木の実でも何でもね
まあこれで十分だよと思っちゃう
思う人だったら楽でしょうに
生きることが だからその
渇愛が消えるたびに すっごく人生っていうのは楽になります
それでまた屁理屈入っちゃうんです
生きることは楽になるんだということは
結局生きること素晴らしいことではないかと
それがまた屁理屈 だからブッダの教えの大胆さっていうのは
あの他の教えは誰が何言っても
世の中の人を言うことは何でも生きることは素晴らしいと正当化する
そうすると苦しみが増える
なんとかして生きてなくちゃいけないんだから
これ素晴らしいんだから
渇愛の話は出てこない
だから世の中にある人間語る教えっていうのは全てまとめて見てください
できれば 全てなくても大雑把でもよろしいしね
とにかく生きることがもうまず前提として素晴らしい
それはもう分かった 分かりきったことで
何も調べようもしてないのに
それで生きる技を教える
素晴らしいんだったら生きる技を教える必要ないでしょうに
楽しく生きるもう 101 の知恵とかね
もう人生は苦欲しない 99 の法則とかね
これでもアメリカで誰かがもうくだらない何かね
もうもう単純なことを何かが書いちゃえば
まあこれはもう日本でもベストセラーで
だから ああいう本を買うこと自体が
自分にとって生きることは苦しいんだっていうことなんですよ
それ認めないこの頭の良さがね
面白いんですよ そこで商売うまくいく
あの秘訣の 7つとかね
それ大体 7つ 90 102 とか
もうそういう本いっぱいあります
それでもずっと読んでいると
読んでること自体も 自分にとってはちょっと問題があるっていうことでしょうね
だから生きること素晴らしいんですが
まあ生きる方法を知りたいんだと
楽に という理屈になるんですね
だからそんなことは仏教は理屈だと思わないんですね
だから正直になれと 大変だったら大変だと言いなさいよと
楽しいんだったら楽しいとはっきり言えばよろしいしね
だから この瞬間で瞬間で物を見て
正直に見るということはしない
総合的に評価しようとする
その総合評価が まあね
まとめて評価するということはもう成り立たないんですね
例えば人生はもう苦あれば楽もありと言って
じゃあまとめて何でしょうかと
なんて素晴らしいかと
じゃあ苦の方はどうしますか？そうすると
だからそれは計算合わないんですよ
ですから 24時間生きてるんだから
その瞬間瞬間どうでしょうか
これがどうでしょう これがどうでしょうかと
1日の研究だけでもできますよ
1 秒 1 秒難しいかもしれません
じゃあ 1 分 1 分メモでも持ってきて
1 分ごとに書いてみてください
楽しいか大変か 気持ちとか何とかに分けて分けてみて
そうすると 1 日で結果が出るでしょうに
そんな難しいことじゃないんですよ
1 日で結果出ます  [背景音楽]まあまあ一応まあ別に生きること素晴らしいというわけじゃなくて
このただ幸福だよと 渇愛がなくなったら苦しみが続かないんだよと
ということで お釈迦様が終わっちゃうんですね
話は それでこの渇愛なくして
心 苦しみをなくす方法って何なのかと
方法がなかったら もういくら立派な教えであろうともね
意味がないんですね それでお釈迦様がまた方法を教えるんですね
その方法っていうのは
まあいわゆる超越道というかね
中道という方法なんですね
中道の生き方だよと それについてお釈迦様は誰も発見していないんだと
これがもう自分にはもう目が現れたんだと
今まで聞いたこともない
知ったこともない真実に目が覚めたんだと
今まで聞いたことがない真実
この八正道なんですよ
それまた聞いたとしても
なんだこれぐらいかと思っちゃうんですよ
そこがお釈迦様のポイントなんです
八正道見てそれが実現実行できないと
言えますかね ジャイナ教だったら 年間断食やらなくちゃいかんですよ
悟るために みんなすごい喜ぶんで
断食とかね 行ったと 素晴らしい修行だとかね
日本でもね まあ千日行やらね
もうあるし あの浄土真宗でもすごい厳しい苦行したりするんですよ
そうするとみんな喜ぶ
素晴らしいです で 他の人にできないんだから
他の人にできないことをやったってもね
ただまあ人気者になるだけのことであって
それで人類救えますかと
救えないでしょうに 八正道っていうのはそういうもう格好つけてないんです
すごい素朴な言葉で まず頭洗ってみなさいと
しっかり物事を見なさいよと
私はずっと喋ってるのはそういうことなんで
だからいろんな考え方はまあ批判はします
批判してきれいさっぱりの頭でもうちゃんと見なさいよと
人の話で見るんじゃないんだと
正見でしょう で そうやって固定概念捨てて
あるのまま見てみると
発見するのは まあ全ては空であって無常であるということなんです
他のまとめて総合評価できる言葉が世の中でないんです
自分の人生観察してみても
きちんと客観的にラベリングしてみたら
いや一年ぐらいラベリングしてみて
じゃあ総合評価してみてくださいと
ちえある人だったら あ
そう教化するんだったら
やっぱりもうラベリングできないんだと
ラベリングしたってすぐ変わっちゃいますしね
修行ラベリングじゃすぐ変わっちゃうし
楽をやったらラベリングした瞬間で空が出てくるでしょうに
あ 瞑想なんかうまくいくそうやなと思ってラベリングするとすぐうまくいかないんですよ
今日はすごい なんか調子が良くて元気だなとラベリングして
ラベリングして間もない
もうもうもう調子も悪くて元気もないというね
そういうことですよ だからそれでも智慧がある人とない人の区別見えます
十年間ラベリング作業しても
智慧がある人とない人の差が見えるんですよ
智慧がある人は何か探してるんです
智慧がない人が 智慧がある人に聞いたら
あんた今十年感やったでしょ
人生って何なのかと もうラベリングを
もうプロだから一つラベルつけてみなさいよと人生に
その人 まあこういうかも
もうラベルはつけませんと一つも
何でしょうか やっぱりすぐラベルをつけた瞬間にもうすぐ違うラベルになっちゃいますからね
それでも一つけてみなさいよと言ったら
まあすぐ変わると 何でも
何でも変わる 固定していないというラベルになる
ところが無常という真理なんですよ
隠れてますかね 無常は
どこにも隠れてないんです
だから私に無常のプロセス聞くことは良くないんですよ
これ自分で発見するんですよ
私が答え出しちゃったら全然何にもならないんです
私が言った言いたかったのは
この智慧のある人がこのラベル総合ついて
例えば十年間の修行したんだからね
ずっと歩いたり立ったり座ったり
もうラベリングしながらやったでしょうと
だから人生って何なのかと一言葉で言ってくださいと言っちゃうと
その人が何も探し求めてないんだからね
もうそんなラベルないんだよと
ラベルつけないんだと
つけようと思ったら無常というラベルしかつけられないというんですよ
でも 何か探す人がそうは言わないんですね
だって怠けは怠けだと思わないんだから
怠けと言うんだけど これは本当はまあ一時的だよと
という気持ちになって
怠けない自分を探せる
探す 怒りが出たら これちょっとかっこ悪いんだからね
まあ一応とりあえず怒りと言うんだけど
自分が本当は怒らない立派な人間やという風な
この ずーっとそういう幻覚で生きてるんですよ
ですから その人に十年間修行したら
あんたどういうラベルしますかと
総合的には まだまだもうラベルできませんね
まだ瞑想うまくいってないんだよと
と言うんです 瞑想うまくいってないんだと言ったら
もうもう分かったもんで
智慧がないと まあ智慧がないもうしょうがないね
だからうまくいってるかないか評価できないはずなんですよ
ですから この正見とお釈迦様おっしゃってるのはそういうことで
ちゃんとありのまま 苦いものは苦いと言えばいい
何が悪いんですかね 苦いものは甘くする方法なんて探すんですかね
そうするとカラクリやらなくちゃいけないんですよ
レモンはみかんの味になる方法とか
で ありますよ あのいろいろあの植物とかね
もう噛んじゃうと このあれ
あの神経がね 塞いちゃうんですね
例えば酸っぱいと感じる神経がもうあの
何と言いますか 塞えてしまう
まあ一時的ですけど そこを噛んで
それからレモン食べても甘いことレモンにある甘い味しか感じないんで
酸っぱいの味は感じなくなっちゃうと
そういう植物もあります
それ調べて調べて 私はもうレモンがみかんの味で食べるんだ
それでいたっても それがカラクリであって事実ではありませんね
ですからカラクリしてはいけないんですね
で 座ったら足が痛いんだったら痛いと言ってください
痛くならない方法は何でしょうか？と聞くと
もう どうにもならないんですよ
だから時々私も腹が立ちますよ
だったら麻酔打てと それしか方法ないんですけど
生きてるものだから 痛いのは痛いでしょうに
だからそれはもう皆様
もう私は外人だから言えないんですよ
もう平安時代だったらそんな人は一回で終わりますよ
と まあいろいろ聞く人がいますよ
甘えて聞くんだけど 一回では
すばりと答える だったら教えなさいと
二度とやらん それでもうすぐもう
まあ目が覚めるんですよ
だから皆様にちょっともう言いにくくて言いにくくて
私にとってはそういうふうに大胆に言うのは
まあやりやすいんですよ
で うようよ有頂天と私は考えませんだからね
瞬時に答えが出ます 痛くならない方だったら
もうそういうしか方法ないんです
うん まあまあ 日本のね
文化っていうのは まあそういうふうなね
風な言葉に慣れてないんだからね
慣れた方がやりやすいんですよ
そんなね  おだてておだてて
そのそういう言葉ね まあまあ
日本語自体は大変な丁寧なね
素晴らしい言葉ですけど
もうそれは社会的ではいいんですよ
でも本当に心身美学を持ちちゃうとすごいハンディになっちゃうんですよ
乱暴でいいんですよ 心はものすごいだらしない
醜い汚いものだから まあそれに適した言葉でいいと思いますけどね
だけどその乱暴っていうのは
このまたちょっとね ニュアンスが違いますけど
やっぱりまあ やりやすいというのはやりやすいんですね
一応そこら辺の話を置いといて
で 正見ということはちゃんと観察することです
で 正見のものすごい大事な反対の言葉ってのは邪見なんですね
いわゆる角度で見るなよと
色眼鏡で見ることをやめなさいと
それで我々に教育させているのは
教育っていうのはとにかく何か色眼鏡を作ってくれるんですね
医者は医者という学問で
その概念で世の中を見ている
他の人々もそのその目で世の中を見ている
で 心の問題になると もう誰かさんがどう言ってるんでしょうかとかね
そういう風にもうとにかくそれに合わせよう
合わせようとしている
だから この一切そういう固定概念は良くない
自分の心だったら自分で見なさいよと
別に難しくはないし 必要なのは正直になることだけ
誰かさんが言ってる素晴らしい境地を探し求めないこと
阿羅漢識を探し求めないこと
もうユンゲいう称号無意識は何なのかとかね
そんなものはもう何も証拠ない嘘ですよ
彼がいろいろ人の心やら文化やらを勉強してたところで
もう言葉借りただけ 人間似ているんだぞと
似ているんだから まあそれが称号無意識ですよとかね
称号無意識があると言うんだったら
はっきりと証拠を出してほしいんだけど
そういう証拠ないにも関わらず
みんな学者たちがそれがもう神の言葉みたいに信じているんですね
ですから そんなことはあってもなくてもどうでも
もし私に照合無識あるならば
自分でわかることであって
それ観察すればもう発見できますよ
ですから そういう概念何も使ってはいけないということをね
邪見と言うんですね 小見というのは八正道の一番に
それぐらいのことを誰にでもできますね
それは苦行でもないんですね
それから考え方はもうしっかりしなさいと
考え方といったっても少々でしょう
それは楽になる考え方を教えているんですね
余計なこの非論理的な欲
それをやめなさいと よくそれ非論理的な欲っていうのは病気なんですね
だからもうただ美味しいご飯食べたいとかね
ちょっと旅に出たいんだけど
お金がないな ちょっとお金
バイトでもしてお金儲かろうかって
そんなことは変 変な非論理的な欲ではないんですよ
すごい具体的で合理的で
そうではなくて 我々の頭の中でとんでもない欲
時々出たりしますね 一人で欲張って考えちゃうと
いくらでも夢作れるでしょうに
あれが危険であって 生きていられなくなっちゃうんですね
だからそういう思考はもうまずやめてくださいと
そんなことはもうどう見たっても精神的な病気なことだからね
それからこの怒りですね
怒りも余計な非論理的な怒り
論理的な怒りっていうのは
もうとりあえず別にそれは後で処理しますけど
まあしょうがないんですね
論理的な怒りはもう処理方法もあります
あの人は私からお金借りて全然返してくれないと言って
ものすごくカンカン怒ると
なんで怒ってるんです？この人は私からお金
この人じゃないんですけど
私がお金借りてね 全然返してくれないんだと
そこでもう論理的だからやはりわかりました
まあ返してあげますと
こうしたらそこで怒り消えちゃうでしょうね
だからそこまで怒るなよとお釈迦様おっしゃってないんですよ
それも良くないんですから
それは修行の結果としてなくなるんだから
別にもうそんなに気にする必要ない
でもそうじゃなくて ただ怒っている
ただ怒り ただ気に入らんという
もう強烈な怒り このテロとかね
そういう怒りで悩んでるんですね
なんでパレスチナ問題解決しないかと
ユダヤ人もパレスチナ人ももうまるっきり非論理的な怒りで
もう憎しみで燃えているんですよ
だからもう解決できないんですね
非力でも殺すっていうこともやったりする
それがやめなさいと 例えば時々日本で見るでしょ
突然誰かがもう殺しちゃうと
別にこのパクリしようとしたところで殺したわけだったら
いくらか分かりますね
意味が それで何か盗もうとしたところで
もう刺して殺してしまったということがね
もう家にもう家を破って入ったところで
もう人がいて 家の中で怖くなって
もう殴って殺しちゃったぞと言うと
理屈わかるでしょ この人はもう空き巣だと思って入った
入ったところで人がいたってところで
自分が顔バレちゃったんだから人を殺しちゃったと
それで理屈成り立ってますよ
そこでもう私たちは道路で歩いてると
誰か後ろから来て刺して出て行っちゃうと
どんな理屈ですかね それで捕まっても
なんであの人 あの人知りませんと
なんで別に誰でもよかったと
というと それはすごい危険であって
処理方法もない 解決方法もないんですね
あれが病気なんですね
ですから そういう余計な怒りやめなさいと
それから物事を考えると
もう相手に対して暴力的なこと
そういうことも思考もやめてくれ
そうするとなんとなく気持ちよくなる
考え方はすごく整理する
残っているのは論理的な欲やら論理的な怒りぐらいのもんなんですよ
それも実行しようとすれば
非暴力主義者だからみんなと仲良くしてあげて
自分の欲をなんとか叶ってもらおうとか
そこは別にもうそんな大したことじゃないんですよ
子供がちょっとお金が十分に欲しくなっちゃうと
それは欲なんですけど
お母さん お前お金くれと言っちゃうと
これはすごい暴力でしょうね
それでくれません で それちょっとお母さんにちょっとニコニコと笑ってね
可愛いお母さんのこと大好きですねとかね
お母さん本当に大変ですねとかね
いつでも美味しいご飯作ったりとかね
お母さんがそれでなんとなくメロメロになったところでお母さんもう 1万円 1万円ちょうだいと
だからそれぐらいは別に大したことないでしょうね
だからそれも欲でしょうし
欲なんです その自分の欲はどうやって満たしたかというと
非暴力主義で あの思考があったんだから
それはまあ実行できるんですね
だからそこら辺はまあまあ別に危険性がね
派手な危険性がないんだから
まあそれはまあ置いておいて
ですから 正しい思想って考え方っていうのは
この非論理的な欲と非論理的な怒りと
これはないとは言ってはいけませんよ
これはもう突然出ます
ですから そこら辺気をつけてほしい
でも突然暴力主義になったりもします
ですから これは暴力主義やと
私は仲良く主義でいきますよと
人が暴力かけてきたっても
私の主義は仲良く主義だからってことで
まあそれで生きていればもうなんとかごまかしができます
だからそこら辺でまあうまく生きていられますよ
で かえってその生き方はもう可愛いでしょうに
するがしかりかもしれませんだけど
憎めないでしょうに 普通の人間の生き方っていうのは
もうすごく可愛くないんでしょうしね
まあそういうふうなことで執行を直すと
まあ次にあるのは まあ全部８も言う時間がないんですからね
まああの正しい言葉語れと
正しい行為をしなさいと
それ全部一つ一つの定義ありますからね
正しい仕事をしなさいと
人生を完善しますね その正しいっていうことは
お釈迦様はただ単にこの浮いてる言葉で言ってるわけじゃないんです
何が正しくて何が間違ってるかとはっきりと教えてるんです
例えば正しい言葉っていうのは
嘘つかないこと 噂を言わないこと
悪口を言わないこと 無駄話言わないこと
4つ選んで守れば もうそれ正しい言葉
他の言葉 全部正しい言葉
言ったことが嘘でない限り
噂でない限り 悪口でない限り
無駄話でない限り 正しい言葉なんです
そこはやりやすいんですよ
悪いことをしてはいけません
正しいことをしなさいと
何が正しいことですかと
なんか迷うでしょうね
簡単に説明します 殺すなよと
盗むなよと 欲しくもない行為をするなよと
他の全部正しいんですよ
それほど明確にしっかりと教えているんだから
そんな迷うところないでしょうに
正しい行為って何でしょうか？今正しいと思ったっても
また後で正しくない場合もあるでしょうとかね
ややこしいことを考えないで
殺すことは正しくないと
だから正しくないものは単純に 3つに分けてやっている
それだけ守ればいいんです
それで正しい仕事って何なのかって
やっぱりそれも仕事のために盗むなよと
人のために殺すなよと
仕事のために欲しがらない
強要するなっていうぐらいのことなの
だからそんなことをして金儲けるなよと
別にこういう仕事 こういう仕事っていうことはもう別に言ってないんです
それだけじゃなくてね
嘘をついてはいけないしね
例えば噂をして あなたの仕事は噂を
なんて言います 散らかすことやと
そういう仕事は良くないんですね
それがこわいし だからまあ
仕事もすごい自慢できる仕事を選んでやればよろしいしね
もうどこでもそういう仕事いくらでもあるでしょうにね
ですから そんな実行しやすいものなんですね
で 次に残っているのは精進ということで
努力しなさいと 努力しなさいと言った途端
また迷っちゃうでしょう
努力って何でしょうかと
どこまで努力すればいいんでしょうかとかね
キリがないこと それはもう変な考え方はそう
お釈迦様はそれを意識をかけているんです
もう余計なことを考える必要ないんです
努力っていうのは あの悪いことをしない努力
それから悪いことしているんだったらやめる努力
それからいいことをする努力
いいことをしているんだったら
それをより完成する努力
4つでしょうね それをできないと思いますかね
それが努力であって それが精進であって
だからいかにぴったし語っているかということなんです
ただ浮いてる言葉で人間が努力するべきですよと
みんなこの精進とか何とか言って書いておくでしょうに
全てこの格言ですけど
浮いてます ほとんど 格言があまり仏教ではないんですけどね
ちゃんと定義まで言いますからね
まあ言葉だけ美しいんですけど
実行できない言葉は全てお釈迦さんは無駄話だと
だから法華経でね もうもう線香ぐらいの詩を歌っても
もう心には何の実践もできなくてね
心清らかにならないんだったら意味がないんだと
一偈でも 一行でもね 心清らかにするんだったら
それこそ言葉だよと そういうことだから
精進と言った途端 もうみんなもうもういろいろこと考えちゃう
欲で考える それで迷う
どこまで努力すればいいかとキリがない
欲の世界で会社は頑張れ頑張れと言うでしょうね
会社の社長に聞いてみてください
もう社長どれぐらい頑張ればいいんですか？と言ってる人は分かってないんです
かえって怒られると思います
怒ったら いい そんなこと言ったって
怒ったって私は頑張らなくちゃいけないのは私でしょうし
ですから 私はどこまでどれぐらい頑張ればいいかというのをはっきり知りたいんだよと
そういうのは欲の世界で量がないんですよ
会社の社長にとってはもういくら儲けたってもいいんだから
もっと儲かれというだけで
社員が過労で死んだって
そんなことは知らんと
それで法律まで作ってるんですね
一番のもう法律もやっぱりもうもうそうやってこの搾取する側を守るためにできてる法律だからね
やっぱりすごい難しいんですよ
ですから まあやっぱりそういう努力のことを言ってるわけじゃないんですね
はっきりコンパクトで
この 4つだよと 悪いことをしない努力
それの努力は必要ですよ
悪いことしやすいんだから
やってる悪いことも習慣でずっとやってること
やめなさいよと これ努力必要だよと
それぐらいの努力もできないんだったらね
だからそういうことをしてみると
みるみるうちに生きることはなんて楽かと
生きること素晴らしいんではなくて
生きることがもう大変楽ですよと
落ち着いてきますよと
悩みもないんだよと 別に
心配もないんだよってことになるんですよ
すごい具体的なんです
で 次にあるのは この 何でしたっけ？正定と
正念と正定ですね で そこは瞑想の世界でね
まあそこ今までのはもういつでも人間にはどうしても必要なことで
だからお釈迦様が成功すれば悟りますけど
成功しなくても成功するんです
人生は 悟らなくてもまるっきり不幸にはならない
だって正見やらね 正語やら頑張ってみてください
正思惟とか いかに素晴らしく
いかに気楽に楽しく生きていられるかと
でも悟ってるわけじゃないんです
するがしこいことするかもしれません
自分の商売をね 契約したくて
相手の人はね すごくおだてたり褒めたりとかね
まあ社長の顔を見ると
本当にもう福の神様みたいんですよとかなんとか言ったりとかね
それでは まあこいつはまあいいやと言ってサインしてハンコを押してくれるとかね
それで儲かったそうってこと
まあそういう生き方は
まあ商売の世界 そういう世界だからね
まあそれはまあ別に嘘ということでもないしね
まあ人を褒めるのは悪いことでもないし
だからまあそれはもう悟った人はやりませんだけど
最近の人々はそんなことはまあどっちもやってることで
それで汚いことをやってほしくないんですね
他にも 例えば八木さんという人がね
もう三人殺しちゃったでしょ
それ自分にお金がないんだから
誰か捕まって その人に保険かけて 三億円ぐらい
じゃあ殺しましょうと
それでいろいろいろいろ工夫して人を殺す
そんな生き方っていうのはね
それはするがしこい生き方とは言えないんですね
逆に もう相手会社の社長を見たら
本当に社長なんか年見えませんねとかね
まあそれぐらい別に政治だからね
と何とか言って 自分の契約をもう動かしてもらうというのは
まあまあそんなことは別に
まあ大したことじゃないし
で ある意味でそれはまあ生きるためのね
まあちょっとしたね まあ技でもある
それをもうすごい面白くやっちゃえばね
面白いし ですから この八正道のね
六つぐらいでも守ってみると
もう人生の苦しみがほとんど落ちちゃいますよ
心配することがね もう倒産するだろうとかね
消えちゃうんです 気楽に生きていられるんです
それで最後に正念正定があるんですね
正念っていうのは もっと厳密に自分のことを観察してみること
サティのことなんですね
で 正定っていうのは統一心統一してみなさいと
そこで観察しながら心を統一しちゃうと
一切は空であることを発見できる
全ては無常であることを発見できる
だから 単なるこの桜の散るところで無常だっていうのは
そんな無常じゃないんですね
そんなことでは悟れません
やっぱりもうその種のレベルで
どう見たって もう全てがものすごい早く変化していくんだと
ということは 強烈にインパクト
インパクト 強く感じなくちゃいけないんですね
それにはやっぱり厳密に集中してほしいということもあります
ですから それはまあ瞑想というかね
実践というところで まあその二つだけが残っているの
ですから この八の八種類の道で
もう大丈夫だよ ちゃんと道も方法も教えていますね
でも本当にそれでやってみれば
だからお釈迦様はすごいチャレンジしてやってみなさいよと
私は福の道 幸福の道を語っているんだよと
苦しみをなくす道を語っているんだよと
他の人々は人生素晴らしいと言っているだけであって
他の宗教の世界は神に頂いた命だからとかね
神に一つ爆弾かけた方がいいんですよ
頂いた命ですけど 下らん命だからね
大変苦労しなくちゃいけないし
苦しまなくちゃいけないしね
証拠もないし ですから
そういうのは生を正当化する教えで
生を正当化の教えでは苦しみが増えるだけ
でお釈迦様はそれを生を正当化するということではなくて
生きることはドッカであると
だったらお釈迦様何語ってます？私は苦しみをなくす方法を語っているんだと
幸福の道を語っているんだと
幸せを語っているんだと
安らぎを語っているんだと
で それは本当ですかと
あなたの教え だったら私を見なさいよと
この中で贅沢しているといえば私ですよと
この中で楽しい人がいるといえば
それは私ですよと ちゃんと自分で証拠を
あんただけでしょうと
だったらみんな見なさい
私の弟子たちやらね 最近の信者さんたちやらとかね
言って話してみなさいよと
どうですかと みんなすごい楽しくいるんだよと
だから そういうふうな
ものすごいもう具体的にお話をしていたんですね
ですから この八正道も世の中でなかった教えだよと
なかったんです 小教を見ると儀式を教えるんですよ
儀礼を教えるんですよ
今 仏教でもやってるね
お経をあげるとかね そんなものはヒンドゥー教から伝わってくることで
神様にこのウェーダ聖典をあげないと
神は喜ぶみたいですね
お祈りしてあげないと
褒めてあげないとね 不思議なことをキリスト教も同じことを言っている
イスラム教も一日回神様をアッラーフアクバルと
神様は偉大なるよとかなんとかなんとかお祈りしなくちゃいけない
ヒンドゥー教でもいろいろもう聖典を唱えなくちゃあかんと
で それでも大乗仏教になってくると
経典をあげるということはもう大変な大事な仕事で
で テーラワーダ仏教でも経典は読みますけど
我々はそれを経典をあげるという部分ではなくて
みんなで仲良く気持ちよく
楽しく 自分も心清らかにするために
勉強もかなえて 暗記することもかなえて
だらしない生き方してはいけないということで
ちゃんと戒めるために言うんであって
お釈迦様に聞かせてあげるぞという気持ちではないんです
ですから 昔のお坊さんたちでもね
まあ若い人々には強引にやらせますけどね
まあ覚えてほしいしね
後の時代までにね 残してほしいんだからね
もう強引にやらせますし
他のお坊さんたちでも
まあなんかやることがないなと思ったら
自分が覚えている経典とか全部唱えてみる
唱えてしっかり もうまたもう何て言いますか
思い出して これはもう直してみるとかね
そういうすごい具体的な行動でしたからね
また時々私でもシャワーやったりすると
やっぱりいろいろいろんな経典とかね
いろんな調子入れたりとかね
一人であげてみるんですよ
すっごい気持ちいいんです
このブッダの世界になんとなくすごい簡単に入っちゃうんですね
そうすると何かいろいろストレス溜まったことあったって
ものすごくもうポチン閉じちゃうんです
それでこんな大事な経典
あんたなんだこのシャワーでって
そのシャワーででも便所ででもどこでもいいでしょうね
気持ちよければ ですからシャワーにいる時間はね
ちょっと長いんだから
まあ経典一つ二つはあげられます
それでちょっとノート変えてあげようかなとかね
いろいろもう遊んだりし
遊びもあるし もうちょっと高い音でやってみようかなとかね
あるいはまあちょっと伸ばしてやったらどうかなとか
だから同じ芸でももういろいろ種類で種類で
もう証明をしてみるとかね
遊びでもあって ともと同時にこの
その教えも内容もね 心に響くんだからね
だから仏教っていうのはそういう儀式を教えてないんですよ
小教というと儀式なんですね
前例があるとかね でもサバットということがあるとかね
必ずそのサバトの日はね
サバトというんですかね
日曜日ですけどね まあお祈りしなくちゃあかんとかね
これもう儀式いっぱいですよ
だからお釈迦様時代でヒンドゥー教
ブラフマン教っていうのは儀式のみでしたからね
だがお釈迦様は単なる合理的に生きてみなさいよということだから
これは未だかつてなかった教えなんですよ
そんな首にいろいろね
まあ虎の歯でしたっけ
それのもう首はかけたり
鼻はかけたり お数かけたり
もう頭にまあヒンドゥー教でいろんな宗派によってこの口に針を刺しちゃうんですよ
口に刺さってここからも出ていくんです
それで一年いるんです
時々この下を引いて それでまた針を刺しちゃうんですよ
だって普段そういうふうに見えますよ
神のために まあ時々そういうヒンドゥ教の人はスリランカの人でもやります
で 下を引いて そこで針を刺して
で 上は何かこのこうやってこの丸くして
だから下はもう針 それでもう舌は外へ出ているし
まあそれ縮んでますけどね
ベロを出してるよりもぶさかってはないんですからね
縮みますから それでもまあ舌には穴があるんですよ
それでご飯食べる時はあれを抜けてご飯食べてまた差しておこう
と それである人に聞いたね
あんたはもういつからやってますかと
またもう 3ヶ月とか今やってます
どこが発祥ですかね  1年の約束をやった
神様にいた だから宗教っていうのはそんなものなんですよ
結局は まあ西洋の宗教ではね
少なくはなってるんだけど
でも儀式儀礼っていうのはもうものすごいんですよ
いろいろ聖人信仰があるでしょ
マリア様の信仰あるでしょうし
いろんなもうイースターってなんとかとか
もうあれ カボチャのあれなんでしたっけ
ハロウィンとかね やってるんですよ
あれはもう原始時代の習慣でしょ
結局やってますから そこが世の中にあるごく普通の宗教ですよ
現代ね 宗教でも見てください
このやっぱり儀式 儀式
儀式で 合同結婚とか それ誰が馬鹿者選ぶんですね
相手は それ自体ヘリクツでしょうね
自分に気に入ってるかどうか自分で決めればいいでしょうに
誰かが決める必要ないでしょうね
キリスト教でも神が決めるんだと
誰かと結婚するんだということは
でも離婚多いでしょうに
神もえらい失敗しますね
神が選んで じゃああなたとあなたを神様が決めたものだから
神の前で約束しなさいって
1年で離婚するんですよ
だから離婚しちゃうと神の言葉が成り立たないんだから離婚禁止する
あべこべなんですよ この考え方が
離婚は認めませんと 清正に反対だと
あびこびでしょうに もし結婚した二人がものすごい仲良く一生死ぬまで一緒にいたならば
それだったらやっぱり神に選んだ人やと言えるのに
逆にしているんです 神が選んだからもう結婚してはいけませんと
イギリス教会はそういうことできちゃったでしょうに
だからこのあびこびあびこびくそでよくも世の中生きているしね
だからお釈迦様の発想道っていうのは
本当は革命的で大胆な教えなんですね
仏教は現実主義じゃないとかいうのはもうとんでもない話で
仏教が現実主義なんです
ローマ法王もそういうことを言ったんだからね
仏教は暗い教えで 人生は否定しているし
現実的じゃないということを言ってね
酷い目に遭いましたけど
スリランカに来る前に言ってもう馬鹿にされちゃったんですスリランカ人に
他の国に対して言ったってもいいんだけど
神の言葉だからさすがそうでその通りだと言うんだけど
スリランカ人はもう人の話でいかない
自分で調べるんだから
それでも反対するぞと
で 教会も謝りましたけどね
スリランカの教会の人々と仲良くずっと生活しなきゃいけないでしょうに
ですからもう謝ってもみんなボイコットしたんです
昔来た時は仏教の人々みんな行ったんですよ
やっぱり偉い人だからね
それは礼儀でしょうということでね
で 王政の人々が行ってね
彼も機嫌がいいでしょうしね
神も同じだからね お祈りすると機嫌がいいんだからね
なんでローマ法王が機嫌が悪くなるの
同じですから行ったんでしょう
それからあとまあボイコットするということでボイコットしちゃった
とにかくまあそれがもうあまり考えてないんだから
そう言うのであって 八正道を見たらブッダの道が八正道しかないしね
これほど現実的な具体的な話があるんですかね
物事を客観的に見なさいよと
努力しなさいよと その努力はこの四つだよと
正しい言葉を語れと 正しい言葉というのはこの四つだよと
で 仕事までちゃんとあって
だから問題なく明るく生きるためにすごく教えていて
それだけでは足らない
ただ生きて生きていて年取って死んだだけになるんだから
すごい大胆なことをしなさいよと
人間のレベルを乗り越えなさいよと
それには正念と正定という二項目も備えてあって八にしているんです
ですから このお釈迦様が仏教を語るんだと
これからはと 言ってすごいわかりやすい言葉で
でもものすごい鋭い知恵で
これはまあクイズみたいな感じで
あまりにもわかりやすいんだけど
なんかどうかと思うちょっとっていうところもあるし
それが五人の比丘たちに教えた最初の説法なんですね
その説法をして お釈迦様
全ては苦しみであることは理解する真理だよと
理解する真理だよと 私はそれはちゃんと理解しましたと
ということで で 二番目はもう渇愛の話はそれはもうなくすものやと
で 私は修行してそれをなくしましたと
三番目はそれを体験するものやと
私はそれをちゃんと体験しましたと
四番目の真理はそれは実践するものやと
私はこれはちゃんと実践して完成しているんだと
いて 一つ一つの真理に対してアプローチまで教えて
それ聞いたら混乱に存じですか？もう悟り開くんですよ
今まで聞いたことがない話だから
やっぱり宗教はこれでしたんでしょうと
これでああなるほどと
で心がもう悟り開いたし
それからもうまたまあこそこそと教えて教えて教えて
他の五人の比丘たちも夜中に悟りましたし
それからみんなまとめてこっちいらっしゃいと
無常・無常・無我の話をしたんです
実体が何にもなどこにもないんだと
それ聞いてみんな完全たる悟り開くんです
まあそこが仏教の話ですよ
はい ではどうもありがとうございました
ありがとうございました